[Musique]
dix neuf en 1992 quadruples meurtre
sordide à brossard défraie la manchette
c'est aux alentours de 19h30 hier soir
la police trouve les corps de deux
hommes des trafiquants de drogue mais
aussi ceux de deux femmes deux victimes
innocentes exécuté de sang froid
on soupçonne rapidement un homme de leur
entourage
un petit criminel daniel jolivet je suis
innocent j'ai été condamné pour des
crimes que je programme des jeux livet
est reconnu coupable des quatre meurtres
et condamné à la prison à vie
mais depuis ce temps la une n'a jamais
cessé de clamer son innocence
tous les éléments qui vient en
contradiction n'ont pas été éduqués
avoir lu tout ça ces documents le
chapeau est aujourd'hui même je
soulèverai un doute
moi non après la pause isabel richer
johan bonnaud réexamine le procès
retrouve des témoins et analyse des
preuves récemment obtenu qui pourrait
jeter un nouvel éclairage sur cette
affaire s'agit-il d'une erreur
judiciaire
bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
lee
notre histoire débute ici au centre de
détention de port cartier à 60 km à
l'ouest de sept-îles nous avons
rencontré daniel jolivettes bonjour et
louise beveridge contente de vous
rencontrer
devait car aucune visite si vous n'êtes
pas seule visite depuis plusieurs gènes
c'était combien de temps que vous êtes
en prison gagné depuis le 14 novembre
992 depuis 25 ans daniel jolivet meetic
il n'est pas coupable que la preuve
qu'ils pouvaient l'aider
li a été caché je suis innocent j'ai été
condamné pour des crimes que j'ai pas
commis en 1994 et où des témoins qui
sont parjurés ans qu'on a la preuve de
tout aujourd'hui avoir eu tout ça c'est
des cuma le rapport est aujourd'hui
j'adore deviendra ma vie
[Musique]
en novembre 1992 jolivet à des projets
il a 35 ans il habite châteauguay mais
planifie de s'installer au mexique où il
doit se marier à la fin du mois avec sa
petite amie
son terrain de jeu c'est le grand
montréal où ils s'adonnent à toutes
sortes de trafics d vol et du recel
jolivet n'est pas un ange l'avait déjà
mis sa réserve et un jump to je pouvais
avoir n'importe quoi il fréquente des
gens comme lui une nébuleuse de
personnages plutôt louche issus du
milieu criminel et chacun joue un rôle
dans cette histoire
[Musique]
c'est aux alentours de 19h30 hier soir
que la soeur d'une des quatre victimes
françois leblanc dont le dossier
criminel est relativement chargé fille
la macabre découverte de trois corps
dans un premier temps outre le corps de
leblanc jc cheveux de deux jeunes femmes
éliminés étant devenus des témoins
gênants informés de la présence d'un
proche dans l'immeuble les policiers se
rendaient à un appartement du 6e étage
découvrant une autre victime
denis lemieux 50 ans le cadre meurtre de
brasse en fait grand bruit
d'autant qu'une fausse rumeur circule
selon laquelle une des victimes était
enceinte
la police veut trouver le coupable en
moins d'une semaine
l'enquêté conclut un délateur s'est
manifesté il n'a pas participé au crime
mais il a obtenu les aveux d'un des
assassins
la police arrête plusieurs personnes
dont daniel jolivet et un individu avec
qu'il fait des affaires paul andré
st-pierre très vite saint-pierre admet
avoir assisté au meurtre il dit aux
policiers que c'est jolivet qui a fait
feu il plaide coupable à une accusation
réduite et il est condamné à douze ans
de prison
c'est le témoin le plus important
pourtant la couronne décide qu'il ne
témoignera pas au procès de jolivet et
arrêtent us pour eux d'être témoin
visuel que marc avicii rythme mais
l'utilisent pas qu au procès le
procureur dira ceci au juge pour
expliquer sa décision
saint pierre c'est vrai que j'aurais
aimé ça le faire témoigner parce qu'ils
placent jolivet derrière la mitraillette
sauf que c'est le seul bout de son
témoignage qui à la moindre crédibilité
le reste est un tissu de mensonges à
l'époque les procédures vont vite
un mois après le crime on tient déjà d'
enquête préliminaire en décembre 1992 à
longueuil
c'est le célèbre criminaliste les ou
rené maranda qui représente l'accusé je
pense pas que tout cas fait parce que du
suspense riche assure votre tour ça sera
tout juste à défendre à pau j'ai dit ok
pas faire le témoin principal de la
poursuite et finalement le délateur
claude rien d'eau un ancien policier
déchu devenu criminel
voici des extraits de séries des
témoignages à la cour je vivais du fruit
de la drogue
j'achetais je revendais un délateur
c'est un témoin que la cour qualifie de
tahri car il reçoit un avantage contre
son témoignage d'autant plus que
riendeau a déjà été délateur dans le
passé l'avocat attaque sa crédibilité
vous saviez très bien que vous étiez
pour être appelé à témoigner
il s'agissait juste d'établir les
modalités à quel prix vous vendiez votre
témoignage de lloret de mar en maître
maranda talonne la poursuite pour
obtenir toute la preuve
mais avant le procès il est forcé de se
récuser pour cause de conflit d'intérêts
c'est l'avocat ronnie mcdonald qu'il
remplace auprès de jolivet
il a accepté de nous parler au téléphone
compte tenu du professionnalisme de
notre jeu parce que j'avais été rassurés
la part de la couronne n'avait fait que
d'aussi qu'on lui avait remis et elle
touche au complet comment vous décriviez
l'ambiance qui régnait dans ce procès de
toute une ambiance lourde
vous savez quand on évoque les heures de
l'accusé qui qui était curieusement la
machine
la machine c'est l'état et ses moyens
importants enquêteur témoin expert somme
d'argent pour amadouer les délateurs
quand un délateur vous amène vers des
suspects on doit faire encore plus de
plus de vérification doit faire encore
plus attention on brasse qui nous donne
et à partir de 3 ans voir faire des
vérifications on va les chercher
l'accord a beau la corroboration pour
les éléments jeunes il faut que ce soit
complètement dépendant soit des preuves
matérielles ou des témoins
on va les corroborer touch iphone dit au
procès le délateur raconte ce qu'il sait
des activités de jolivet la journée des
meurtres
j'ai rencontré monsieur jolivet la
première fois le 9 novembre à la cage
aux sports sur la rue concorde la ville
de la balle autour de la table françois
leblanc et denis lemieux qui sans le
savoir vivre leurs dernières heures
françois leblanc est un vendeur de
drogue et il fait du recel denis lemieux
est un trafiquant de stupéfiants
bien installée et un ami de longue date
de daniel jolivet le délateur est allé
les rencontrer
c'était concernant un montant d'argent
de 8000 $ eux nous avait avancé ce
montant d'argent là pour une cargaison
de l'aveu à vaisselle et sécheuses voler
la cargaison a été saisie par la police
et riendeau a une grosse dette envers le
blanc et le mieux il jure qu'il va les
rembourser justement il prépare un
nouveau coup le vol d'une cargaison de
fruits de mer
leblanc à 2 kg de cocaïne à vendre si
riendeau à des acheteurs il pourrait se
renflouer
[Musique]
daniel joly veille son partenaire saint
pierre se joignent à la discussion
selon le délateur il y à de la tension
entre le blanc et jolie fête jolivet
propose d'aller récupérer des
mitraillettes qu'ils appellent des
balayeuses dans leur jargon les armes
serviront à faire le vol pour rembourser
les 8000 $
direction rue d'iberville où se trouve
une cache d'armes
c'est à ce moment là qui dit on va aller
se rencontrer au motel nittolo on veut
louer une chambre puis on discutera de
ça
le groupe se rend donc dans un motel de
l'ouest de montréal
dans une des chambres les quatre hommes
vérifie le fonctionnement des armes
on cherche des acheteurs pour les deux
kilos de coke et on en consomme
sauf genivi selon riendeau jolivet et
enragé contre françois leblanc il teste
les armes en tirant plusieurs rafales
dans le matelas de ton très agressif
on va la règle et leurs corps ont valeur
arranger le portrait faut pas attendre
fouilles à l'étude
les policiers corrobore cet événement
raconté par le délateur
il ya eu l'utilisation des larmes
africain s'est remis dans un motel qui
avait été il y avait été tiré des coups
de feu dans les matelots c'est d'aller
chercher ces policiers les maltraiter
ses preuves le avec des techniques des
techniciens se décline ensuite les
hommes se séparent mais riendeau dit que
jolivet l'appel plusieurs fois pour lui
parler de leblanc et il semble déterminé
à en finir avec lui le quadrupède
meurtre a lieu dans la nuit du lundi au
mardi dans deux appartements de cet
édifice de brossard les corps ne seront
découverts que le mardi soir
le délateur n'est pas témoin des
meurtres mais il raconte au jury que le
mardi matin avant même la découverte des
corps il prévient un policier car il est
inquiet il faudrait que je te parle de
quelque chose qui se passe ce tracé en
note les noms de lemieux et le blanc je
m'en vais déjeuner à pointe saint
charles avec le duel
il se rend au restaurant barabé à pointe
saint charles pour le petit déjeuner
vers 9h15
il déjeune à tanger nivet qui n'arrive
pas il lui téléphone à nouveau
finalement jolivet arrive portant le
chapeau que sa fiancée mexicaine lui en
faire au japon comme clint eastwood
ça fait qu'ils s'associaient ma droite
commande son déjeuner moi je continue de
prendre mon café et servir d'abord
mauregard pim dit ouais c'est réglé j'ai
été tués tullow doigt puis même pièce la
dette que vous aviez pour l'heure pour
la vente saisi à la grande surprise de
l'avocat de la défense
on appelle la serveuse du restaurant à
la barre elle dit avoir servi les deux
hommes le mardi matin 10 novembre lyon
déjeuner puis ils sont partis tout de
suite après qu'ils ont déjeuné
[Musique]
et elle était dommageable pour votre
client effectivement dommageable puisque
madame la lente et le chu témoins qu'il
prenait d'une façon directe corroborer
les prétentions du de la terre le swing
d'ô qui a payé la facture s'il monsieur
quand vous parlez de ce monsieur là où
je vous parlais de l'accusé oui la
serveuse identifie daniel jolivet elle
évoque même son chapeau elle dit l'avoir
reconnu sur une photo montrée par les
policiers peu de temps après le meurtre
[Musique]
on présente au jury un croquis de la
scène de crime
au premier étage le pathologiste dit que
les trois victimes de cet appartement
sont mortes entre 21h30 et 2h30 du matin
ensuite le ou les assassins sont montés
au sixième étage chez denis lemieux
je suis incapable de dire combien de
temps après mais il est de mon opinion
que denis lemieux a été tué après les
autres lors de perquisitions on a trouvé
des armes à feu caché par jolivet le
même calibre qui a tué les victimes
mais l'expert en balistique ne peut pas
les relié au crime
l'arme du crime n'a jamais été retrouvée
ni les deux kilos de coke qu'on essayait
de vendre cette journée là on a aussi
trouvé quelques milliers de dollars sur
jolivet
[Musique]
un expert décrit les déplacements de
jolivet grâce aux cellulaire fixe dans
sa camionnette
une trentaine d'appels sont décortiqués
devant le jury les tours cellulaires
confirme sa présence au restaurant de
laval à midi puis sur la rue d'iberville
au motel dans l'ouest de la ville
chez le blanc à brossard vers 18 heures
puis au même endroit après minuit on ne
fêterait la triangulation avec des
techniciens deux belles époques les plus
chauds ils sont allés dans la bâtisse
dans les appartements des victimes et
ont fait les tests
josemans les policiers ont refait le
trajet à bord du camion de jolivettes
leurs appels sont captés par les mêmes
tours cellulaires
c'est le coup de grâce la défense
appelle un seul témoin la femme de denis
lemieux
l'une des victimes qui explique au jury
qu daniel jolivet était un ami de son
mari et qu'il n'a pas pu le tuer plutôt
minces comme défense l'accusé jolivet ne
témoigne pas sa version des faits n'a
jamais été entendu
c'est un choix stratégique qui lui sera
reprochée plus tard c'est vrai que ce
soit le j étais chez chez françois est
donné c'est vrai que je tends possession
d'armes chez wreckage dès mardi mais
jarre a corroboré la faille dernier
doute ça posait pas trop de risque de
témoigner
oui c'est ce que fait comprendre
effectivement tout repose donc sur le
témoignage d'un délateur appuyé de
preuves dit circonstancielle trouver la
part de sujets toi y'a pas vraiment un
jury de douze personnes trouvées en
arriver à la conclusion aux clients de
tous
le jury délibère trois jours plus tard
le verdict tombe
daniel jolivet est coupable des quatre
meurtres et condamné à la prison à vie
sans possibilité de libération avant 25
ans
malgré le verdict daniel jolivet reste
inébranlable
il dit que ce n'est pas lui qui a commis
ces meurtres après la pause
son véritable combat commence
[Musique]
daniel jolivet a passé son enfance dans
un quartier ouvrier animé où les ruelles
était peuplé d'enfants mais où la vie
était rude
celle des enfants jeux d'hiver commence
mal
gardiens des gens d'affaires puis avec
une mère monoparentale qui faisait son
possible avec deux enfants assez
difficile
c'était dur tiens c'est vrai ça marche à
coutras le jeu tu as tout le temps comme
ça
diane c'est la soeur cadette de daniel
joly fait on est tendu complice du frère
il n'y avait rien pour nous séparer en
fait à part eux il faut que ces fêtes
place étant tous ces affaires nous est
si proche en nage donc vous faire aider
il faisait un mauvais coup en jean
daniel jolivet fait des petits vols puis
des crimes plus graves
il entre et sort de prison régulièrement
il ya eu des voleurs ouvrage est un
voleur
chers frères daniel et un petit
délinquant à cette époque sa soeur et
elles consomment des stupéfiants
même s'il désapprouve sa consommation
daniel ne la laisse pas tomber dans la
peau trop d'argent dans ce cas va pas
que jacques rousseau vit à place du
marché de l'épicerie dans ces années là
dans le temps que je consommais
le petit délinquant devient criminel de
carrière vol frau de recel son casier
criminel se remplit
jama de violence jamais porte sur
personne ben voila je tairai salaires
moi je tape pas un assassin il tend même
à nous battre les plus jeunes ces points
et puis allez c'est pas un viol un pas
tout le
jolivet est bien décidé à faire
renverser le verdict de culpabilité
en 1998 la cour d'appel lui donne raison
81 18 mai 81 18 la cour d'appel du
québec a ordonné un nouveau procès en
2000 la coach premiers ont caché les
nouveaux projets alors pendant toutes
ces années là jamais changé d'idée vous
vous êtes jamais dit up tant pis je
lance la serviette jeu non non j'ai tout
le temps cherché des traces de demandes
d'accès à l'information demander de
l'aide à tout le monde
j'ai écrit des lettres à des universités
des différents goûts noms d'avocats
puis je suis certaine réponse qui me
choque jeu mais sensible à votre cause
mais je crois qu paix puis ses
successeurs puis il ya juste l'aide
juridique de montréal puis demi un père
leader qui m'ont répondu on à la parade
d'identification l'ida sahara nour est
aujourd'hui avocat de la défense entend
parler de la cause de jolivet en 2002
l'universite auront tous avaient fait
une conférence au projet innocence puis
ont expliqué qu'au québec il faudrait
avoir des projets menaçants ce parce
qu'il n'y avait pas assez de monde qui
prenait négocié francophones dans le
cache les étudiantes à cette époque là
je reviens à montréal avec tout mon
courage et desire on part le projet
innocence au québec
le projet innocence né en 1992 aux états
unis vient en aide aux prisonniers qui
estiment avoir été injustement condamné
dans les années subséquentes les
nouvelles techniques d'analysé de l'adn
bouleverse les méthodes d' enquête et
permettre d'innocenter des centaine
d'accusés depuis plus de 350 condamnés
américains ont été exonérés au canada on
parle de vingt-et-une personnes
les cas les plus célèbres david milgaard
accusé en 1969 a quitté en 1992
guy paul morin arrêtée en 1985 et a
quitté après dix ans de procédure
roméo fillion libéré en 2010 après 38
ans en prison
l'arrivée de l'ida nouerait dans le
dossier redonne espoir à daniel jolivet
ou du bus jusqu'à coupable selon elle a
tous voila paulus le là peuvent la
police daniel de taper un petit mais le
leader de jeu 2 2 c'est pas mal de jeu
je sais pas - aide - souplesse en 2003
on a commencé à rencontrer des témoins
2004 on a commencé à voir des documents
de l'accès à l'information des documents
qu'on n'a jamais vus comme ce joli vert
jamais vu que la défense avait jamais vu
par exemple je vivais obtient la
déclaration d'un bijoutier de verdun
rappelons que le délateur riendeau a dit
avoir reçu les aveux de jolivet le
lendemain du meurtre alors qu'il déjeune
dans un restaurant de pointe saint
charles
or jolivet affirme qu'il n'est pas allé
à ce restaurant ce matin là j'avais tout
mexique la semaine d'avant
puis la semaine d'avant dalle au mexique
hélène et mon âme à van mander je veux
tu me rapporte un sombrero un chapeau
mexicain qu'à la place un chapeau
mexicain est l'aîné mons était la petite
amie de paul andré st-pierre
elle voulait une breloque comme celle ci
je veux demander si pour m'apporter une
ce cadeau d'un ami commun bijoux 14 mai
à survenir
mon ami de mes copines
personne n'a pas passé à 58 me la faire
à faido table
là j'ai fait deux trois bijouteries à
châteauguay on n'a pas ce n'est pas en
avoir encore toute la déplace à montréal
s'appelait 14 avoue débutera vers 20
heures
j'en ai plusieurs plus on voit ça le
tout ça analyse de toutes les 4 1 les
femmes les bijouteries diabète ou es ce
que vous avez ça un sombrero un nom à
passeront en a pas on a bossé jusqu'à
tangent panien c'est oui oui on a un oui
au gardien wendel et pour jari jouets 2
[Musique]
le bijoutier déclaré aux policiers
j'ai reçu un appel d'un individu qui
voulait savoir si j'avais un chapeau
mexicain
ils étaient tous le matins il voulait
venir tout de suite en avant midi
nous lui avons offert de lamballe et il
n'a pas voulu pour ne pas que le bijou
ressemble à un bijou acheter ici mon
employé m'a dit qu'il portait
probablement un chapeau et il ressemble
au monsieur sur une des photos que vous
montrez et il désigne la photo de givet
le bijoutier s'appelle georges bossé
celui qui deviendra maire de verdun
c'est sûr qu'elle épaississe avec
appelée debbie ajouté parce qu'ils sont
allés rencontrer un bijoutier qui a
appelé ceux ci démontrait encore une
fois que c'est un passé qui soit deux
places en même temps et qui n'étaient
pas au déjeuner
nous avons parlé à georges bossé mais 25
ans plus tard il n'a pas de souvenir de
l'événement
ça fait partie des difficultés dans ce
genre de dossier une deuxième
déclaration même l'équipe de l'ida
nouerait vers un autre témoin une femme
arrêtés dans la semaine qui a suivi le
cadre bleu meurtre son petit ami de
l'époque graviter autour du groupe
criminel de paul andré st-pierre
elle devrait à pointe saint charles au
début des années 90 elle a refait sa vie
ailleurs nous l'appellerons louise elle
raconte un épisode qui s'est déroulé
dans la nuit du meurtre
vous êtes dans un bar avec votre
conjoint de l'époque qu'est ce qui se
passe à ce moment là bang ordi dans sale
on avait les pages est fait que y aura
un appel par padgett vague easy je mens
à faire une commission de janvier donc y
était
minuit minuit car finalement il est
revenu il était 14h45 le lascar ce soit
le lascar l'ined est annoncée trois
heures d'absence exactement aux heures
entourant le cadre uc le meurtre
quelques jours plus tard la police
procède à l'arrestation de jolivet et de
plusieurs personnes de son entourage y
compris louise et son petit ami gordy
l'arrestation et muscler la gauche
qu'elle est malade vous êtes des mental
j'ai dit ouais le loge insectes et je
comprends absolue marie l'imam n
appartenait libéré après quelques heures
d'interrogatoire
louis s'apprête à retourner à la maison
mais avant ils m'ont laissé tout seul
avec gordy dans le bureau à l'époque
luiz ne parlera pas de ce qui va suivre
c'est là que s'est approché de mon
oreille pays maudit quand tu arrives tu
t'en vas dans le sous sol
tu vas voir un sac de sport j'ai dit on
leur met à quelqu'un il va aller le
chercher
est-ce que ce qu'ils vous disent que
dans le sac non le vous arrivez chez
vous oui
j comme curieuse la pile heure je me
disais c'est quoi mais quand j'ai ouvert
j'ai fait là non non non qu'est ce que
vous voyez une mitraillette avec pas
loin de 2 kg de cocaïne
comment vous réagissez chaque data sur
un shop bien bougés par je ne sais pas
avec qui j'ai affaire qu'à relire
minutes j'ai ouvert la porte puis j'ai
même pas regardé de famille dit je veux
pas je veux pas qu'ils sachent que je
les ai vus comme ça il pourra poser est
ce que je le reconnais tu comprennes
dans un cauchemar la jugent peu qu on
savoir dans quoi je m'embarquais avant
de quitter gordy pour de bon elle lui
pose des questions
lui m'a dit que c'était paul andré
st-pierre qui avait remis ça qui avait
demandé de rester à celle ses paroles
rappelons que paul andré st-pierre c'est
le complice de jolivet il a plaidé
coupable à une accusation réduite de
complicité après le fait dans les
meurtres de brossard le récit de cette
femme consigné en 2003 par l'avocat de
daniel jolivet jette un autre éclairage
sur les événements
[Musique]
c'est entre autres avec ses éléments en
main que l'ida nous ré et jolivet font
une demande au groupe de la révision des
condamnations criminelles le grc s'est
il s'agit d'un comité spécial qui
examine les dossiers classés par la
justice lorsque les condamne y
soutiennent être victime d'une erreur
judiciaire
c'est le devoir du groupe de révision de
les évaluer et de dire à la toute fin
est-ce que c'est suffisant pour avoir un
impact ou chat aurait pu avoir un impact
sur la finalité du procès en 2007 et
2008 les demandes de génie besson refusé
le jir cc trouve que la déclaration du
bijoutier est très vague
l'histoire du témoin qui aurait
découvert un sac avec une mitraillette a
été vu comme étant non plausibles
selon le groupe de la révision des
condamnations
les nouveaux documents obtenus par
jolivet n'ajoute rien jolivet tente de
refaire son procès alors qu'une demande
de révision exige des nouveaux faits et
des nouveaux faits le grc ci n'en vois
pas il souligne que jolivet n'a pas
témoigné pour sa défense
s'ils désiraient démontrer son innocence
jolivet aurait bénéficié de l'occasion
lui revenant de témoigner en sa faveur
plusieurs remarques de grc ont fait
sursauter le criminaliste très respecté
que nous avons consulté le droit au
silence ça des plats bien du monde mais
c'est un droit fondamental protégé par
la constitution
pendant l enquête de police pendant le
procès on demande à l'accusé de ne pas
refaire le procès dans la révision ceux
qui analysent faire la même chose et
puis le grc s'est fait cette remarque
étonnante jolivet n'a offert aucune
preuve scientifique réfutant que la
mitraillette qu'il avait en sa
possession a mené à la mort de quatre
personnes accusées les pros obligé de
faire entendre des experts
elle lui a reproché de pas de la voir
faire mon avis était très déplacée et ça
pouvait fausser l'analyse mais faut-il
le rappeler
l'arme du crime n'a jamais été retrouvée
on peut se demander si ceux qui ont
étudié la demande de révision
connaissait vraiment où les fêtes
dossier
[Musique]
déjà 25 ans que les portes de la prison
se sont refermées sur daniel jolivet la
prison à vie pour des meurtres commis en
les années passent mais son but n'a pas
changé il veut un nouveau procès je veux
être jaune arrêt devant un juge ou des
jurés de te dire vous êtes à côté de ces
accusations je suis on retire les
accusations c'est encore mieux non tu
pas bons et sont les retire ça veut dire
on n'a pas de preuves non non non mais
pourquoi après avoir purgé 25 ans
obligatoire ne peut-il pas sortir parce
qu'une sentence vie qui accepta posa sa
sa sentence et qui n'y a aucune chance
d'apporter aux libérations
conditionnelles michel donne est un
ancien avocat qui a été condamné pour le
meurtre de son associé en 1981
réhabilité il a accompagné des détenus
purgeant de longues peines il connaît
bien le processus d'acceptation de la
culpabilité quand quelqu'un arrive en
prison avec une sentence vie c'est clair
qu'il doit faire un deuil
alors ils dénient premièrement alors on
veut pas accepter ça ensuite il ya la
colère et le marchandage la dépression
et enfin l'acceptation et à la fin de
cette phase d'adaptation là quand la
gauche réussit accepter sa sentence qui
a accepté la responsabilité de son juste
alors là ils peuvent faire les
programmes qui vont l'amener à un peu
plus loin dans le dans le processus de
sa sentence mais cette période
d'adaptation là elle peut durer quand
même entre 2 800 et même des gens qui
qui la traverse pas
michele dunne a purgé 18 ans de prison
il à nier sa culpabilité pendant des
années il a même écrit un livre pour
clamer son innocence
moi j'ai signé mon délit pendant sept
ans et c'est exactement ce qui s'était
passé
en fait le procès auquel moi j'ai été
confronté je sais pas savais tu avais
aucune allure les policiers ont menti
les médecins spécialistes ont menti le
chimiste a menti l'expert en balistique
a menti et ça moi je me suis insurgé
contre ça c'est ça mon combat mais
j'oubliais que moi aussi j'avais match
j'ai livet est-il enfermée dans un
mensonge
il jure que non et continue de nier sa
culpabilité
qu'est ce que c'est l'impact pour
quelqu'un qui nie éternellement 6.2
design va faire son dix ans mais pour
une sentence vie ça ne finit jamais
alors il sortira pas de prison c'est un
impact catastrophique à moins qu'ils
réussissent comme je les dis à prouver
l'innocence qui est pas toujours le cas
contre toute attente en 2016 jolivet
reçoit encore une fois de la preuve non
divulgué le groupe de la révision des
condamnations accepte alors de revoir sa
demande pour une troisième fois très
exhaustif de toutes les appels qui ont
été faites pour démontrer que nuit
finalement au moment des moeurs et au
moment du restaurant-bar année ils se
retrouvaient pas à ces places-là de sa
cellule
jolivet établi une chronologie des
événements un casse-tête géant qui
pourrait peut-être le sauver par mu a
déjà mis tout ça donc le moment de
l'humeur possiblement on regarde ici on
voit sous jolivet il ya des appels
téléphoniques dans la preuve obtenue
récemment daniel jolivet trouve une
liste des appels cellulaires analysés
par les policiers il examine sans
relâche les éléments de l'enquète
surtout la nuit des meurtres
à quel moment vous êtes allé à brossard
chez lemieux leblanc mais l'ubs minuit
quand je reste 15 minutes
parce qu'on voulait les appels que je
fais quand je me rends à l'offre je
vivais admet être allé sur la scène du
meurtre ce soir la portée de l'argent
ainsi que la drogue invendus il repart
pour aller reconduire saint pierre son
complice lui et vous et que vous êtes
houle le rapport à une heure du matin
les victimes sont toujours vivantes une
des deux jeunes femmes assassinées a
appelé une amie à une heure et quart
avant de se rendre à l'appartement de
brossard ou la mort valve a frappé au
sixième étage denis lemieux est lui
aussi au téléphone
denis lemieux à 1h30 cette nuit
visiblement encore dix ans des
déclarations des voisins de l'immeuble
de brossard parle de bruit autour de 2
heures du matin
l'offre continue mais le fort qu'avant
tout le punch à l'afp on remercie bleus
voulaient faire 90
nous avons étudié le témoignage de
l'expert quand téléphonie et les cartes
déposé lors du procès les relevés des
tours cellulaires ne confirme pas la
version de jolivet notamment entre 00h30
et 2h20 cette nuit-là l'appel 2008 58
qu'il dit avoir fait de
pointe-saint-charles n'est pas capté par
la tour de ce secteur mais plutôt par
une tour située plus à l'ouest selon la
preuve cette tour relayé aussi les
appels faits près du fleuve à brossard à
proximité des lieux du crime
la version de jolivet n'a jamais subi
l'épreuve des experts en cours
aurait-elle soulever un doute
raisonnable
jolivet à une thèse
le délateur claude riendeau de principal
témoin contre lui serait beaucoup plus
impliqué qu'il ne le dit et il avait un
mobile pour tuer les victimes
il leur devait de l'argent nous sommes
retournés chez éléments la petite amie
de paul andré st-pierre à l'époque elle
confirme que le matin du 10 novembre 92
claude riendeau est arrivé avec une
cruche remplie d'argent et de bijoux
claude riendeau est arrivé avec un butin
avoir battu pour les shows de cruche
briois de cloche de même à l'appel d'un
groupe d'ados parce qu'il ya beaucoup
dit suda beaucoup de large à l'oti quand
tu as des bulles de brebis débile de
cinq cartes parce que j'étais si mal
quand j'ai vu ça une cruche qui se
trouvaient dans l'appartement de denis
lemieux
c'est sa fille qui disent aux policiers
et jolivet vient tout juste d'obtenir sa
déclaration dans la nouvelle preuve
un autre document révèlent des
contradictions dans le témoignage de la
serveuse c'est pas un élément c'est pas
deux éléments par inadvertance qui paula
s'est tous les éléments qui viennent en
contradiction n'ont pas été divulgués
pour l'avocate de jolivet on a
systématiquement omis de divulguer tout
ce qu'ils pouvaient disculper son client
ce qu'elle appelle une vision tunnel
quand on a une ses ennemis blondissez la
personne qui est coupable mais là on
essaie de trouver toute la preuve
alentours pour démontrer que la personne
et pas ceux du tonneau est jeune je
pensais ce qu'est ce qui est arrivé dans
ce lot s'il est pourquoi vous pensez
qu'ils avaient ciblé jolivet à tout prix
monsieur jacques desse n'est pas la
personne qui est blanche comme neige pic
jamais
qui aurait jamais eu de démêlés avec la
justice isabelle johan quand on parle
d'erreur judiciaire
immédiatement on se demande bon est ce
qu il les a tuées oui ou non on peut
s'interroger sur ce que ça veut dire
d'ailleurs être victimes d'erreurs
judiciaires parce qu'il ya pas que la
notion de culpabilité qui entrent en
ligne de compte non effectivement c'est
une notion qui est beaucoup plus large
que ça et d'ailleurs la notion de non
divulgation de la preuve ça entre là
dedans parce que pour garantir le
caractère comme on dit juste et
équitable d'un procès il faut que l'état
fournisse toute la preuve contre un
accusé
pour lui permettre de se défendre vous
poursuivez votre enquête après la pause
et vous donner la parole à d'autres
personnes concernées par la démarche de
daya jolivet après la pause deux points
de vue des familles des victimes
[Musique]
les années passent mais les familles des
victimes sont incapable d'oublier le
drame surtout les proches des deux
jeunes femmes dans la vingtaine à
l'époque nous avons contacté la soeur de
catherine morin carole elle tenait à
rendre hommage à sa soeur mais elle
souhaitait le faire par écrit ce
reportage et le dos si jolivet
bouleverse notre famille au plus haut
point
mais nous avons trouvé la force en nous
pour honorer la mémoire de catherine
catherine c'était notre cadeau du ciel
notre rayon de soleil à tous comme toute
grande charge des toujours couverts
quand elle faisait des mauvais coups
malheureusement je n'ai pu la protéger
de cette crapule qui nous l'enlever
brutalement lorsque j'ai vu à la télé le
coroner sortir le corps de ma petite
soeur dans un sac
une partie de moi est parti avec elle
mais je ressent toujours une douleur
vive on vous écrivant cette lettre il
devant le combat de daniel joly verts
qui soutient être victime d'une erreur
judiciaire
pour ma part cela me laisse indifférente
ça ne me ramènera pas catherine j'ai
recueilli les commentaires de certains
membres de la famille et des amis
qui pourrait s'en est offert c'est un
criminel alors ça me laisse indifférent
oui si effectivement il le pot commis ce
crime
quelqu'un fait une maudite belle vie sur
le dos de jolivet le policier à la
retraite jacques saint-pierre qui a
contribué à l' enquête est encore
convaincu 25 ans plus tard que jolivet
est coupable fut convaincu de suite
l'air dans ma taille que si un des
auteurs de ce guide le plus mûr que le
même si soulèverait un doute
moi dans ma tête une pointe doute c'est
aujourd'hui presque impossible de savoir
avec certitude ce qui s'est vraiment
passé cette nuit là
mais une chose semble établie daniel
jolivet n'a pas reçu toute la preuve au
moment du procès ce qui est un élément
essentiel pour obtenir un procès juste
et équitable
des notions qui ont l'air bien théorique
mais qui nous interpelle quant au
système de justice qu'on souhaite avoir
la communication de la preuve
sans rentrer dans le concept de procès
équitable la question n'est pas de
savoir s'il est factuellement coupable
la question est de savoir est ce que le
procès était équitable et six ans
quelque part quelqu'un décide qu'on a
pas joué franc jeu qu'on n'a pas
respecté les normes
monsieur le verdict qui est entachée on
doit annuler le verdict qui a omis de
divulguer de la preuve à la défense
j'ai eu beaucoup de monde de rencontrer
ce oui on aime beaucoup mon maintenant
les déclarations toutes les déclarations
qui ont été prises s'était auto d'eau
aussi sa salle été transmis au procureur
maintenant si c'était pas pertinent de
les donner à la défense ce soir le
procureur de l'époque est décédé
l'avocate de jolivet a voulu consulter
le dossier de la poursuite pour savoir
ce qu'il contenait
mais étrangement le dossier a disparu
[Musique]
le temps qui passe rend les démarches
plus compliqué ces décideurs retracez
les témoins des témoins que des fois
veulent pas être tracés ou quand ils
veulent être tracée pour la mémoire et
plus comme qu'il était des fois aussi
sont plus disponibles sont décédés
lady peace du restaurant n'existe plus
la bijouterie a fait place à une
épicerie les lieux où les événements se
sont produits ont disparu comme
plusieurs témoins
la serveuse du restaurant est décédé le
délateur claude riendeau est introuvable
peu après le procès il a été condamné
pour d'autres crimes
de sorte qu'il ne pourrait plus
témoigner contre jolivet comme le
policier à la retraite le soulignait
dans un rapport la possibilité de
présenter l'ancien preuve est impossible
étant donné que le délateur claude
riendeau a été arrêté incarcéré et son
contrat brisé par son acteur de ma
conjointe est décédé d'un cancer du
poumon
ma mère est décédée d'un cancer m'ont
parlé de celui d'un gars n'a pas marché
j'ai pu par sean daniel g livet continue
d'y croire et avec son avocate
il envisage d'autres avenues si ottawa
refuse encore une fois de rouvrir son
dossier mais il ne cache pas que la
perspective de vieillir en prison
commence à l'effrayer
[Musique]
de retour à enquête isabelle daniel
jolivet les toujours en attente d'une
décision d'ottawa
effectivement le groupe de la révision
des condamnations criminelles lui promet
une réponse depuis l'été dernier
c'est toujours repoussé mais là ça ne
devrait plus tarder parce que l'avocat
qui a étudié sa demande par à la
retraite alors évidemment il doit
vouloir conclure ces dossiers bon en
attendant sa décision on a tous nouveaux
projets à l'émission une nouvelle façon
découvrir plusieurs de nos enquêtes
c'est vrai en lien avec cette histoire
la sphère jolivet il ya un balado
diffusion qui sera disponible sur le
site web et aussi sur l'application
mobile de radio canada qui est
disponible d'ailleurs dès maintenant
c'est déjà tout pour nous cette semaine
au nom toute l'équipe merci d'avoir été
là on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour une autre enquête
[Musique]